I asked someone they said yeah Daniel
came on the show for the first time in
2004 yeah I've watched you grow up yeah
and then watch me grow old well no
that's assault I'd like I I've now
realized like I am just gonna be like
the most horrible yardstick of like how
old everyone is yeah the rest of my life
I don't see me now and go like oh god
that must mean I am also old yeah like
it's a ya know it's it's disturbing
creepy we don't interesting is that uh
we have tons of celebrities I meet all
the time but we you let me take a
picture with you backstage I sent it to
my kids and they're like no way you
can't know him yes I can know lots of
pianos more impressive people than me no
no no you're at a whole different whole
different league I'm very excited about
yes I'm very happy you are working on
this show miracle-workers and it is I'm
very excited about this project I got to
watch some of the show I loved it and
it's you're working with one of my
favorite creative minds mr. Simon red
yes it's just got to be a blast
no he's amazing isn't yet acquainted
with Simon's work you have a wonderful
treat in front of you yes
both is his short stories on the book
that this is based on they're just
amazing and yes he's a delightfully a
funny inventive guy and he this is a
very funny idea first of all your your
role is to play an angel and I thought
yeah
Daniel Radcliffe is sort of perfect to
play an angel that I think very kind you
think that's a sweet per face very kind
of you might Mike my grandmother
disagrees vehemently with you cuz like I
said this I said to her that I was
playing an angel and she just went like
that's bad casting yeah if you'd like to
made that like little winky joke and my
grandmother is 96 years old and is is
you know is not as lucid as she once was
so a few moments later she asked me
again what are you up to soon and I was
like I'm doing a show called miracle
workers I'm playing an angel in it and
she immediately was like that's bit
miscast even even in like the eighth
season now she has this joke locked and
loaded too
like no matter yeah if I say I'm playing
anybody relatively nice yeah yeah I like
it forgetful it's no comment yes
yeah yeah just the same ones over